-♪ Virtual Reality
Pictionary ♪
-First,
we're going to need partners,
and we've found some good ones.
Joining my team, she stars
in the movie "The Glass Castle,"
which is in theaters
this Friday.
Please welcome Brie Larson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You feelin' it, pal?
Let's do it.
Tariq, Brie.
-Hi.
-Tariq's partner tonight, you
can see him in the new movie,
"Naked," on Netflix this Friday,
and his new show, "Marlon,"
premieres next Wednesday on NBC.
Give it up for Marlon Wayans,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on.
Great to see you again, buddy.
-What's up, brother?
How you doing?
-Oh, I get so jealous
when I see this.
I just want to -- I want to
rob your face for a beard.
-All right, all right,
here we go.
Now, look -- now, this --
This game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person who's drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets
and drawing in 3-D space
using a program
called Tilt Brush.
We'll be able
to see their point-of-view
up on the big screen upstage.
45 seconds per turn.
I'll go first.
You guys
can all take your seats.
There you go there, buddy.
All right.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughing ] Gosh.
-Wait. So, me and him's
on the same team?
-Yeah.
-Are we guessing?
-No, not yet.
-Okay.
-I'm guessing.
-Yeah, you're gonna guess
when I -- when I draw.
Oh, I got to
pick a number first, sorry.
Uh...
Which one?
[ Audience shouting ]
Four is right there.
I guess I'll just do it.
There we go.
-Jimmy, no cheating,
'cause you cheated me last time.
I remember --
I remember that.
-I didn't -- I didn't cheat.
I never cheat.
-You've played this before?
-Not here. It was another game
he cheated me in.
He's good in cheating
all the games he hosts.
-Never -- I don't cheat,
and you've never
played this before with me,
so here we go.
This is a thing, okay.
Oh, can I say --
Can I say what it is?
It's a person --
-You can't say.
Can you say?
-See?
There goes the cheating already.
I'm telling you all.
[ Laughter ]
-I can say the category.
Yeah,
person, place, or an animal.
That doesn't even help.
-That's all the things.
-That could be everything.
That's everything, almost.
[ Laughter ]
What a bad hint that was, yeah.
Person, place, or an animal.
Oh, boy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay, okay.
Oh, I see what's going on.
All right.
Marlon, don't do anything.
Marlon, don't do anything weird.
[ Laughter ]
Don't do anything weird!
Marlon, just sit there, please.
-I'm protecting you.
You're fine.
-Ready? Here we go.
-Person, place, or an animal.
A flower?
A sombrero.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, a cactus?
A bow tie.
A hat with a pinwheel thing
on it?
Oh, you're bad at this.
[ Laughter ]
A bumblebee?
Yoshi.
A butterfly.
Uh...popcorn?
I'm really stretching here.
-Jimmy's drawing's so bad,
his parents
wouldn't even hang it up.
[ Laughter ]
This is terrible!
-I'm afraid --
-A potato.
-Wait. I can't --
-Let me help you out -- vomit.
-A butterfly!
A but-- A butterfly's nest.
A butterfly net.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh! Oh!
Tha-- Oh!
That was
the longest drumroll ever.
And I tell you,
the cheating's in.
-I just broke a sweat
playing Pictionary.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I -- Can I guess now?
For points?
-Yes.
-It's a cocoon.
-No.
-That's a good guess, though.
-A dragonfly.
-What?!
-Oh, my God.
-You didn't draw a dragonfly.
-I didn't?
-No, you drew a butterfly.
Dragonflies have a longer body
and smaller --
-Okay. What was the vomit
that you drew?
-That was the tail -- the tail.
-Of a what?
-Of the dragonfly.
[ Laughter ]
-What dragon does this?
-You're up next, Marlon.
Here.
-Oh, me. Okay, cool.
-Pick a number first, and then,
I can help you with that.
-This gonna mess my naps.
It's your show.
You don't want to do...?
[ Light laughter ]
-Wait. No.
First, wait, stop.
First,
I have to give you a thing.
Wait. Hold --
-I can see. I see.
-No, you have to take --
-I see it.
-No, no, I know you see this.
You have to look
at the clue first.
The clue.
-Oh, okay. There we go.
-All right, which clue --
Which one should he do?
[ Audience shouting ]
-84!
-This is like
"The Price Is Right."
-This like
"The Price Is Right" -- 1, 4!
Number 3! 7!
All right!
I'm gonna go with 5! 5!
-Gonna go with 5, all right.
-5!
-Okay, 5.
I don't want to see it.
Tariq guesses this.
-Whoever picked 5,
please see me afterward.
We fighting.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I say what it is?
Ready?
-Here we go.
[ Clock ticking ]
-A cat, a kitten.
-A kitten.
"Tom and Jerry."
Um...
A puppy? A dog?
A mouse?
It's a cat, right?
Is it a rock--
Is it horse, a rocking horse?
What is that?
-Use the space!
This is fantastic, by the way.
-This man is --
You can't get this?!
This is Picasso right here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The devil!
Hell! The devil!
-That's one.
-Dante's "Inferno."
-What?!
-That's one.
-"Devil in a Blue Dress."
-You got that part, right?
Now, you got to get this part.
-Which part?
-Let me do it again.
All right, come from over here.
Ready?
[ Buzzer ]
-You didn't give me
no drumroll!
You didn't even
give me a drumroll!
[ Laughter ]
-Not everyone gets a drumroll!
-Hey, man!
Last time I checked,
you black, too!
You have to give the drumroll!
-Hey, come on!
It's not a racial thing!
It's not a racist thing.
It's gonna be all right.
-Talk to your man.
[ Laughter ]
And it's a deviled egg.
Look, I -- I know it's food
we don't eat, man, but come on!
[ Laughter and applause ]
We've been to white barbecues.
They like deviled eggs, man!
-White barbecues.
Oh, my gosh.
Deviled egg.
I didn't know --
It looked like a dragonfly,
that last one.
All right, Brie, you're up.
-Oh, I'm up?
-Yeah.
-Ooh, the pressure's on.
You guys were really good.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait.
I got to pick something.
What's my number, y'all?
[ Audience shouting ]
7.
-And then you pick it up
with this.
-Oh, you've
got to be kidding me.
-Wait. Is it hard?
Is it hard?
-It's hard.
-Yes!
-Okay.
This is a movie.
-Yep.
-Ready?
-Yes.
[ Clock ticking ]
"Jurassic Park."
[ Laughter ]
Uh, uh..."Jaws"!
"Sharknado 5"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That was good.
-I mean, come on!
-That was good, right?
-That was good.
"Sharknado 5."
-Where did you see a shark?!
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't see a fin?
-That looked like a foot
with some glass in it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Guys, Tariq, it is your turn.
This is the final round.
It's gonna be a showdown.
If Marlon guesses
the clue first,
then you guys win.
If Brie or I guess it,
then we win.
Okay?
There you go.
-You got to guess --
How you guess when I start?
-It's the last round.
[ Audience shouting ]
-So, we can guess on this?
-Yeah, we guess it, too.
-we get to guess it?
-Yeah, if we guess it first,
we win.
[ Shouting continues ]
-Okay.
-You guess it.
-It's easy.
It's a phrase.
-It's a phrase.
Easy.
-Yeah.
-All right.
-It's a phrase.
Here we go.
-You want to move out the way
a little bit, brother.
Thank you.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Clock ticking ]
-You got to pull the trigger
on the thing.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Camel.
-Camel hump!
Wave.
Dinosaur.
Camel.
-A phrase.
A dino-saur.
-Old as a dinosaur.
-A bronto --
Dinosaur.
-Check --
Check your dinosaur grass.
Checks and balances.
Hump --
-Hump -- Hump day.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who got that?
Hump day, right?
-Yeah.
I said it!
-Did you get that?
-I said "hump day"!
-What'd he say?
-Hump day!
Wednesday. That's today.
-See, you busy talking trash!
-I said "hump grass."
-Hump grass?
What is that?
-Time-out!
You got 62 Roots!
You give me the dumbest one
out of all of them!
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
You got 62 of them!
-What is he doing?
No, no, no!
My thanks to Brie Larson,
Marlon Wayans, Tariq Trotter.